what's up guys upcoming dates I'll be at
Cherokee Casino this coming weekend in
West Siloam Springs Oklahoma and that's
already sold out then I'll be at Yuk
Yuk's in Calgary June 15th and 16th
Canada June 23rd temblor brewing
Bakersfield June 29th the Paramount
Theatre and that's in rural Stark County
Illinois
June 6th through 8th in Oxnard
California at levity live July 20th
through 22nd charlie good nights in
Raleigh
August 16th through the 18th The Laugh
Factory in Chicago September 14th and
15th Zanies in Nashville just added
Toronto the Just for Laughs festival
September 27th through the 30th you have
to buy the pass and then you have to
choose me as one of your artists I would
appreciate any support we can get there
after that I'll be in Appleton Wisconsin
in Buffalo New York I'll give you those
dates soon but they're on the website
all tickets at theof on Comm slash tour
tou r do you have a cold sore or let's
be frank with each other
do you have herpes or herpes herpes
it's much more common than you think
people have it who has it people animals
might have it I don't know if animals
you know if they get down like we do but
it is treatable many people don't
realize that the for the treatment to be
effective you've got to start taking
medication within the first 12 hours of
experiencing symptoms well they got a
new thing out there and it's called her
polar t' and her polar tis the first
telehealth application that offers
diagnosis and treatment for the herpes
simplex virus that's right it's 100%
secure confidential and encrypted it's
herp alert
it connects patients with physicians to
address their cold sore and herpes
needs here's how it works you complete
an online questionnaire upload pictures
send your señor select your pharmacy and
pay a one-time fee that's right go to
herp alert calm hg RP alert dot-com all
right let's see what we can do here
[Music]
all right
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
[Music]
died
have some fun while we all die I know
that's a little bit of a dark tune right
there but that is the Spencer Jacob
growl band and that is their song
celebrate and Spencer gave us that song
to use right when the podcast started
and Wow I want to thank everybody for
the support you know we've been doing
people have been listening and tuning in
I'm coming to you live if this sounds
weird or this is you know sounds
different than usual I am dude I got
this ramshackle set up here at this
hotel in San Francisco I'm here this
weekend and I've been performing at
cluster fest and cluster fest speaking
of cluster that sound like something you
might want to get checked out on her
polar but her Pollard is a real thing if
you got to get that you know if you find
you got a lot of used to looking
splotchy or your cousin all of a sudden
looks like a leopard he's got that
leopard neck because he'd been out you
know test-driving locals with his tongue
and you know putting things in his mouth
and being wild and being frisky and
letting the springtime fever just just
just tempt him and tempt him to be
naughty or her to be naughty because
everybody can get it if you get in that
splotchy achi then you can go on a herp
alert and check it out and you can get
it diagnosed I'm not gonna know nobody's
going to know that's between you and
your doctor but sometime you get that
it's you're like what is that you know I
got a group of moles that showed up that
seems extensive but that could be her
polar that could be hurt that hurt by
her paw hurt they had to do live by me
growing up named Herbie and when you
think about Herbie is it's about as
close to her P as you can get and Herbie
there was this dude I remember he wanted
to be he wanted to be tall so bad and he
couldn't be tall because God didn't want
him to be tall and whoever you know his
grandparents or whatever whoever you
know did sex and made him they were
small and when small people [ __ ] let's
be honest it's not there's nothing wrong
with it everybody
everybody can [ __ ] no matter you know I
think as long as you're like three feet
tall you can [ __ ] but you're not gonna
you don't the odds are you getting
something real long out of small sex or
limited you know the odds of that are
kind of limited and then this boy hurt
this boy Herbie
always wanted to be taller but he was
just you know a basic heighted man and
he would comb his hair up real high and
he would wear these tall tall shoes and
the shoes were probably 3-inch heels but
they were full you know flats they were
three-inch flats and I mean he he never
looked tall he looked like a he looked
like a short person stuck between some
heels and really combed high hair that's
what he looked like somebody that was
like he had bookends the heels and the
hair and he never made it real tall in
that boy that man's name was Herbie and
he played with us in the neighborhood
sometimes and he was natural he didn't
do anything wild even though sometimes
people want to be wild he didn't do
anything like that but thank you guys
for being here with me today you know I
just got a limited set up out here and
I've been out here in at cluster fest in
San Francisco and this city is man this
is the most diverse place maybe I've
ever been outside of San Jose California
do you can't even if you wanted to be
racist you couldn't you can't tell what
anybody is you couldn't be racist really
if you really wanted to because you
couldn't narrow [ __ ] maybe you could not
narrow it down you know if you want to
get on racist this is a place to come
because it's just so and everybody's
gender neutral and then gender fluid and
double gender and you know people got
you know people have they might have a
penis but they got vaginas tattooed all
around their penis and they got ever
it's you know it's a real I mean it's
his full throttle it's full throttle up
here when it comes to when it comes to
diversity but thank you guys for tuning
in man I had a you know I had a lot that
happened this this weekend I want to
thank
everybody to four you know we hit a
hundred episodes last week and I don't
know if I want to get into it because
the voicemails and stuff you know I'm
running off a just my own laptop and I
don't have my producers here you know
not that I need my producers to help but
I I don't want to electrocute myself
because some of this equipment he looks
pretty Randy this [ __ ] seems pretty you
know just a little bit Randy to me so
can you guys hear me better is that
better
sorry you know I had um I'll tell you
this listen what happened me last night
so last night you know I'm feeling like
I'm feeling it's late at night and
sometimes at night for me my crotch
starts to think and it starts thinking
about you know other crotch though you
know the other kind of crotch
and so that's kind of happening to me a
little bit just natural cuz I'm here by
myself and you know I had an arm
I had a smoothie and so I try to drink
that because that's not like you know as
smoothies not like a vagina but it's
like porn a vagina down your throat a
little bit so I had a smoothie hoping
that would take the edge off of my you
know my my wiener trying to be you know
trying to be fancy and trying to look
out the window like I cuz I got that
kind of dick I'll be laying in bed and
I'll see my dick over there looking up
the blinds like dang my dick trying to
be around about trying to be around town
and so anyhow I I was feeling kind of
depressed actually and I'll tell you
what happened next I'll tell you what
happened next but first yeah I'm feeling
kind of depressed I woke up fell asleep
I woke up like 3:30 in the morning and I
went downstairs to smoke a cigarette and
hadn't been having any cigarettes
meaning because I didn't want any and I
had Nana I hadn't had any for three days
and I was feeling so proud of myself
because that's the hardest thing to do
they don't care you know I know some
people have been prisoners of war and
stuff like that in that [ __ ] I'm sure
I'm sure it's tricky you know being
locked up for monitor
years even and stuff like that but also
what is tricky is quitting cigarettes
and getting that nicotine just expunged
from your body and I'll do anything man
I you know I was I was doing all kinds
of stuff to not be around that I was
doing deep breathing like kind of Lamaze
they almost say you know if you do like
a Lamaze people don't realize this it's
for pregnant ladies to help them get a
baby out of their you know their that
front booty that push but it also will
help you if you are having a craving for
a cigarette
you know Lamaze is powerful people won't
use Lamaze as much as they should I mean
you could be in traffic and do some
[ __ ] in that and it will help you
Lamaze underestimated but anyhow I wake
up 3:30 I went downstairs to have a
cigarette and and when I left out of my
room out of my hotel room they had a
girl in the hallway bouncing around this
some little Muppet this tattooed you
know I mean she was like a damn
Neanderthal or Neanderthal ax or
thoughtless a Neanderthal stris she was
just bouncing around like a ping-pong
ball and in the hallway and I saw her
and I walked by her and I said are you
okay ma'am and she just kind of mumbled
something and then I thought oh she
might be drunk but then also thought she
might be sleepwalking because people
people do all kinds of stuff in their
sleep people don't realize that you know
how to uncle used to jerk off in his
sleep and they made him wear these
jingle bells on his wrists to shut him
down you know in some nights we'd hear
we'd hear him in the other room you know
what I'm saying
- and through the snow and that was um
and it wasn't even a seasonal thing and
it's kind of scary when you're thinking
about you know you wake up out of a cold
sleep and you hear jingle bells and you
think it's Christmas but then it's just
you know it's somebody in the family
yeah an amp
you know spraying out in their sleep so
it's hard to hold that against him you
know it's because it's kind of
paedophilia behavior to be masturbating
and knowing that there's children in the
next room but if you're doing it in your
sleep then who's to blame there you know
you're
subconscious you know I mean that is
that's really second-level Dark Arts
there so anyhow anyhow I got up the
girls in the hallway she was bouncing
around I thought she was maybe just
walking and just walking around in her
sleep in the hallways and they said oh
nope don't wake somebody up if they're
sleepwalking or whatever because they
might I don't know why they say that
actually you know why do they say that
don't wake them up you might scare them
yeah well you know what also might scare
them that they're [ __ ] walking around
in the middle of nowhere that's scary
that's kind of the dumbest rule don't
wake somebody up if they're walking
around in their sleep here's my new rule
[ __ ] wake them up and tell them hey
jackass
shut it down or I will get a damn you
know one of those blow dart guns or
whatever they used to you know when
monkeys get out on television and then
some man shows up and shoots it and it
falls off the power lines but it's gonna
wake up later and being like a safety
cage I'll get one of those weapons
anyhow I go downstairs and I have this
cigarette and they got a you know San
Francisco this place has mastered the
art of homelessness I mean they have and
I think part of it is so expensive to
leave it live here you could be a
regular person here with a regular job
and you're [ __ ] you are home unless
you know you are sans casa so I go down
there I have my cigarette I come back up
this girl is walking the same way down
the hallway that I am when I'm walking
back to my room it's 4:00 a.m. she's
right up on me and I said ma'am are you
okay
she's like Yee she was kind of a [ __ ]
to be honest and I'm not saying she was
a [ __ ] as a woman am i calling a woman
a [ __ ] I'm saying this [ __ ] was acting
like one and I put my key in the door
she comes right in my room like beelines
kind of right in like a really fast
sleepwalker like somebody that's sleep
running now it's like running in their
sleep bruh like the nocturnal Carl Lewis
you know what the [ __ ] that's dangerous
but you know they say you're still not
supposed to wake them up because they
you know they might you might
Scarah so and she doesn't have shoes on
and she wasn't homeless looking this
lady looked you know she was a bit of
kind of a frump c'n you know she was
that she looked kind of like a I like
kind of a like a little bit of a
marshmallow meatball and she rolls in
she had a couple tats and [ __ ] she gets
straight into my bed and lays down puts
the covers on her and I'm like damn this
Nizhny inch is Goldie locking she's out
here Goldie locking man so I get alarmed
right because this is dude this is me to
central here this is San Francisco
they're waiting for some dude to jerk
off off of a balcony or something it
lands on a lady's shoulder next thing
you know she's suing so it's you know
everybody's busted up around here but
he's upset and fired up and looking to
you know they're hanging libidos from
every street lamp male-male libidos so i
propped my door open now because I don't
want my door closed I don't want there
to be any you know miscommunication I
don't know this woman she's laying in my
bed so I said ma'am and I'm saying ma'am
because I don't want there to be any if
somebody over here is something I don't
want anybody hearing girl or anything
that sounds wild anything that's gonna
get daddy locked up or get my dick and
her nuts locked up so I start saying you
got to go you got to go and she looks up
and she's like don't be mean and then
lays back down don't be mean I'm not
being mean this is my room you know
you're squatting so she keeps me me and
she keeps saying stuff and I'm like you
need to go she's like she's like pit pit
pit you know like I'm not good like kit
like leave me alone so I'm thinking well
man I'm gonna call the front desk and
and here's the thing like but if I call
the front desk then I'm thinking they
come upstairs are they gonna believe
just me are they gonna believe some man
that there's a girl in his room he done
no she is what if she wakes up and says
I did something
that's all she has to do is to wake up
and say he did say he try and then I'm
in trouble man I was like I was scared
and then I was gonna make a video and
I'm like but then I'm thinking with up
with this video up what if she doesn't
like the video you know what if she sees
it she gets upset at it then she could
accuse me of something just to make
herself feel better so finally I went
over there and shook I'm I know you're
not supposed to wake these people up if
they're sleepwalking but I don't give a
[ __ ] at this point this lady is sleep
trespassing you know she said I don't
even know who she's working for if she's
working for you know the devil I don't
know what she's doing you know she has
um narcolepsy when I was in junior high
we had a UH this a librarian and he was
a beautiful kind of mix gentleman he
said he was French and he might have
been who [ __ ] knows dude nobody
listened to the librarian but he this
man Pierre Fabra and Pierre Fabra would
fall asleep and he would like be
teaching us about the Dewey dance
mmm and he'd fall asleep with his mouth
open and he looked like a little sugar
doughnut you know he was um you know he
had that beautiful French color kind of
a you know a beige and I said you know
I'm all about power he had that beige
for that beige tint you know that black
and white kind of that Rhonda's Jean
that mix going on side of him and he
would just he would be like oh you guys
need to read he falls he was his mouth
open so then us kids we would try to
shoot spitballs into his mouth while he
was asleep
anyhow finally I get this girl up and
and I walk her out another I tell her
she has to leave I kind of walk her out
into the hallway close the door and
she's gone
and I'll lay down say a little prayer
because I don't want to get in any
trouble and I didn't do anything
and and then uh like 30 seconds 30
seconds later I hear her arguing with
somebody like two doors over I'm sure
she just went to the next door and tried
to get in there but I'm guessing she
didn't have any shoes on and she didn't
have dirty feet so I'm thinking that she
probably
if I had to guess she was sleeping in a
room she got up to urinate and that's
normal or natural you should never feel
ashamed about that and then she got
stuck
she went out though the door of the
hotel room and into the hall and setting
on in the bathroom and then she got lost
in and confused but man that had me you
know first of all if I was a straight
pervert dude I could have you know
there's some guys that would act it out
you know that would have ruffled them
feathers that would have tried to [ __ ]
that goose you feel me
so I was thankful at that moment that I
wasn't just a straight pervert or a
straight you know I was just cuz you
don't know sometimes until you get in a
position let's be honest you know I can
tell you right now I would never do this
I would never do that I would never do
that but you don't know you say you
don't steal but what if there's a
million dollar suddenly just sitting
somewhere next to you you know it's like
you just don't know sometimes what
you're gonna do until you're there but I
was glad that I didn't have that dark
artist inside of me that sponged you
know that uh that flared up and popped
you know popped some you know popped
[ __ ] or something went at this girl or
tried to you know even just touch a
titty or something like that and she you
know she was kind of she didn't really
take care of herself like I don't mind
like I don't mind you know some strong I
don't mind uh some gristle but she had
that just she was real floppy disc and I
like a little bit more of a hard drive I
don't mind that gristle you know I don't
mind that you know I don't mind uh you
know these skinny gals something I was
like making love to a can of pick-up
sticks you know it's like kind of
putting your penis in a pillowcase full
of deer antlers you know I like a girl
that's got a little bit of that that you
know a little harrumph to her so that
was something wild that happened what
else outside of that I just had kind of
a crazy week in here man I had a couple
of sets I got to open up for Jim
Jeffries and that was magical with him
and Forrest Shaw who's one of the
writers on the Jim Jefferies show and I
got to work with them and there's 5,000
people in this venue and so
man you walk out and do it it feels let
it it feel like and it felt I didn't
feel special you know because I feel a
responsibility I feel you know my
responsibility is to entertain is to
make these people feel some kind of joy
or make them laugh or make them you know
make them feel something good so I felt
you know here's what I felt I didn't
feel super nervous so I felt like I
could do my job and so then I felt I
felt grateful I felt good I felt good
that man I'm so glad I don't feel
nervous right now so that I can do my
job well because you know seven years
ago or something I get a you know I do a
big theater or get out I would have been
way more nervous and so it's nice it's
nice to not have that and those nerves
just you know just nerves for me nerves
are like these little bitty reminders
all over like it's like these little
reminders just hanging off your your
your soul and your brain and they just
remind you that maybe you can't that's
what my nerves are like and that's I
don't like feeling that maybe you can't
maybe you can't
maybe you can't they're like these
little like just ornaments on my son
must if my soul was a tree and there
were little ornaments but they're
they're they're they're they're mean
ornaments and they just all just have
maybe you can't written on the ornament
and that's what it feels like a lot of
times when I get nervous but I was happy
to not have him then fast forward I did
a show outside and I won't do this again
dude it was outside it's in front of
like the Capitol or something in San
Francisco I don't know and I had to go
first and I told my manager I don't I
don't do well going first because the
first person has to warm the crowd up
and I'm that's not my strong suit you
know some things people are good at like
if you play baseball you might you know
some people are good at batting some
people good at second base pitcher some
people get it outfield some
some people are good at coaching some
people are good at just standing off to
the side a third-base scratch in their
crotch when other people run by but one
thing that I'm not good at is one thing
I'm not good at is starting out the show
because it's like what you got to get
everybody warmed up and excited I'm more
of a little bit more I feel like a
relief pitcher not a close I'm a close
I'll [ __ ] close but I'm just I can't
work that first inning I don't do it
very well and man I had to get out there
and do it it was it's like nine thousand
people and they were not feeling me and
it was just one of those sets sometimes
you have a set and it ain't man it just
do to Matt it's like it's almost like
you're your brain once to leave so bad
it's almost really gone but your body is
still out there you almost feel like a
mime because you're still doing all this
stuff getting no reaction from 9,000
people I heard or this might have been
my imagination but I thought I could
hear somebody sneeze about 200 yards
away that's how bad I felt like it was
going and you know people had warned me
they're like look you can't hear
laughter outside you know especially in
these environments because it just goes
up into the air there's nothing to keep
things around but man I felt I felt just
shattered and that's kind of this
business it's like you can have a high
and then a low I mean I was coming off
the high of being in this theater
there's 5,000 people in there and
everybody had fun and they they were you
know it's almost as if I was talking to
one person and I was feeling that joy
and then you get up there and that joy
just you know just like - you know -
ms-13 or show up and just treat that joy
like a dog then the worst part for me I
got off stage and they had like this
there's nobody back there suddenly when
I got offstage when I got on bunch of
people were back they
people having cocktails you know
somebody got a new dress you know people
are chatting everything and then I get
off and nobody suddenly nobody's back
there it looked like all their like all
the real estate was like for lease
suddenly oh and then I'm standing by
myself and do you ever see one of those
you ever seen one of those little
whirling dervish things those little you
ever see like a little Windtunnel
startup like in the middle and like
you'll just be walking on the street and
suddenly a bunch of trash will start
hanging out with each other in a circle
like it's a big gangbang for like trash
and and dirt like it's all just [ __ ]
real fast in the air before anybody
catches it suddenly one of those kicked
up right on me like around my feet and
around like I was Pigpen from like I was
like I was Pigpen from that show so that
that was uh that was just so then
anybody that looked over not only could
you tell I was dejected but then I have
this magical little dirt nado
rolling around my feet oh so it was a
trying it was just a trying time but we
had some special voicemails that were
set up to spring is here we had some
voicemails that were set up just to be
you know to show some gratitude that
people have sent in about the hundredth
episode but I I'm not I'm not in the
studio so I'm reformed we'll play a
bunch of those I'm gonna try to play a
few voicemails and hit some callers that
came in but this episode's gonna be a
little bit ad libbed and sometimes
that's how it is man what else is going
on oh I got some good news so Ridge
wallet they're one of our sponsors and
if you never if you don't have a Ridge
wallet me you should get one they're
dope and it's a pricey item I'm not
gonna lie to you that's a pricey item
they got you know and it's at Ridge
wallet calm slash Theo and but they it's
like a front pocket wallet so especially
like here in San Fran I notice if you
have a wallet in the back your pocket
one of your butt cheeks is kind of up in
the air a little bit and if you sit down
like that I know
when I have that big butt wallet that a
lot sometime a lot of men will think
that I am trying to be you know get
extremely natural with them or you know
get extremely fancy or you know sensual
because you're sitting it like a you
know you're kind of propped up a little
bit and you got that you know one of
your everything like one of your tits is
a little higher than the other one one
of your shoulders a little higher
because you know you got that that
regular wallet under your butt and I
noticed that a lot of men will be like
oh who's that little you know who's that
little prudent little flamingo of a tear
but it's like it's like no not buckaroo
you know I'm trying to just I'm you know
I'm vulva only for daddy but but they
don't see that because you propped up
cuz one of your butt cheeks is higher
than the other and it gives you that
flare and a lot of men will take that
flare is like a flirt action so the the
ridge wallet as you put it in your front
pocket but we got a really dope thing
Ridge wallet has said that you know
everybody knows you know we've been
supportive of this young gentleman named
Mickey he just got them knew them knew
them knew duffels he got them new lungs
in his body and the lungs he inherited
actually came from a drug addict a man
that was on crack cocaine probably a man
here in San Francisco statistically
speaking dude it is uh it was sunny this
week but also this weekend it was also
probably a 70% chance of crack outside
and but Ridge has said that they want to
bring Mickey down and they want to take
him and me
skydiving together so he doesn't even
know it yet he may hear this episode and
learn about that but I thought that that
was pretty magical that they reached out
and did that so we're grateful to them
and and that's so that's something's
gonna happen we're gonna hat that'll
happen we'll put it out on we'll put
that out on regular YouTube well I was
gonna say we'll put it on patreon but
that's a real thing you know I don't
know if Mickey can take them crack
Long's up in the atmosphere you know I
don't want him finding a new addiction
because that's another thing I'm worried
about for trickling Mickey is that if he
has lungs that were addicted to crack
okay and that man died but those lungs
still alive you know them crack sacks
and if now if Mickey has them you're
telling me he might not start smoking
crack someday that's kind of wild to
think it's really really kind of wild to
think you know in the future you know
who knows what happens in the future I
thought about this the other day
wouldn't be cool if you had a pair of
pants right and if you urinated in them
the the pants were just like one color
like white but if when you urinated in
them the urine the moisture revealed a
design in the pants so instead of people
being like dang boy you know Sherman
pissed his uh pissed his knickers
instead they'd be like damn Sherman got
them uh then Picasso pants or it makes
like a you know a cool style so you
could piss your pants but suddenly you
know you got these maybe a pine trees or
something that show up on them so that
way it would you know it would diffuse
because you know we don't do much as
adults when you're young and you urinate
yourself that [ __ ] just it's just one
clump of urine in the front it would be
neat if they had a pant that could
prevent that and you know create art at
the same time but yeah anyway my mind's
all over the place man it says you know
I'm out of my element I mean here I'm
caged up in the corner I can't even tell
if this audio is working good this [ __ ]
may all be blown out but sometimes this
is how it is you out here on the road
you know when I was a little intimidated
this weekend man I've never really
performed in San Francisco and you know
sometimes I just get in Timm like this
place is you know so you know it has
that vibe of being super liberal and I'm
you know I feel like I follow all around
in the middle or I don't know where I
fall you know I'm just trying to [ __ ]
be realistic about things but you know I
just get uh there was certainly some
moments where I was nervous about doing
some of my material and um and that's
wild it's wild to think that because you
can't you know in some places you can't
be sarcastic especially in a big
environment when the when the
environments smaller then you can
starcast
you could do sarcasm anytime because
people can get it well when people are
you know 600 yards away sitting there
listening to you the sarcasm
homelessness doesn't play but I had
another set tonight I got to work with
Bert Kreischer and that was magical and
you know I noticed this is a comedian
you never have two bad sets in a row and
I believe that you never have two bad
sets in a row and I knew after that
second set getting go to my like and I
was like I know I'll have a good one
next time and uh and thankfully I did
let's check it we'll try some voicemails
here man let's see what we can do it is
it's almost summer release June this
June let's hear this yeah this is Eric
what's up Eric from Baton Rouge down
there in the red stick and my brother
lives down there and he has three
children down there and they're all his
children and his wife's let's hear it
Louisiana and June first and I just saw
I had junebug so just wanted a comment
on the punctuality of the insect
community oh thank you for that call
Eric you know and I'll say this Eric you
think mother nature's not gonna be on
time yes June you saw a June bug dude
doesn't mother nature but whatever clock
we have this wallet this time X or
whatever this iPhone that [ __ ] is that
don't matter
mother nature's got the clock she's the
one with the but she knows when this is
all gonna end mother Nature has that
clock so she she might send out a June
bug or a December Viper whatever that
[ __ ] has got these animals on time I
mean she's the real Barnum & Bailey you
know people want to talk about feminism
and you know female empowerment I could
could there be any greater powers in the
world then then the feminine wiles
mother nature this it they don't say
Daniel nature they don't say Richard
nature they don't say Lavelle trous
nature or yangsun mother nature it's a
woman and she's cracking that whip dude
only a woman could keep all this so
organized all the gardening of the
universe pushing the waves up and down
up and down doing volcanoes I mean
that's who else would do a volcano
beside maybe Kim Jong yeah Kim Jong yeah
Kim Jong ken no you know who the [ __ ]
I'm talking about
milah little Korea that little Korean
you know that little dude he looks like
uh he looks like a pizza chef kind of
buddy from Korea uh he yeah he would
maybe do volcanoes outside of that
mother nature but yeah she's sending
junebugs man she'll do whatever the
bison she's got them ready to rock when
they need to run across the Serengeti
she knows that 90 of them are gonna get
hit by lions she knows what's up mother
nature ain't playing games so I'm not
surprised man but I appreciate that call
let's take uh let's get another one here
well we'll rock in and out of a few
calls man if this appears to be working
thank you guys for joining us this week
we'll get back to a regular episode we
might do it on Thursday a full episode
instead of have a guest who might do
we'll do something I do want to
celebrate a little bit more the fact
that we made it through a hundred
episodes dude I remember there were
nights I was doing this and I did not
want to honestly you know night there
would be nights where you know
especially when I first started I was
real heavy and new you know and a lot of
y'all know this into the dark arts and
then they're doing you know self
pleasure and self skete you know and
just see eating out and pleasure myself
I remember one day I had just just
abused myself really to exhaustion
sensually you know looking at just you
know different types of lab ia's and
everything on the internet and you know
I was just caught up and I just you know
my body there was nothing coming out it
was like as even a 0% chance
any [ __ ] really flying out of my body
and I'm not trying to be vulgar but I am
trying to be honest with you right now
and I would still you know have to put
that you know I'd still put the podcasts
up and now is crazy you know just just
not wanting to but still put setting the
cameras up and getting it set up and
getting audio and and then the editing
dude in the beginning we didn't have it
set up where you could play a voicemail
or a song and have it all be in the same
audio track so we had to take the
separate audio tracks and lay them all
in and sync them up man I remember being
noon the next day I'd been up all night
and I wasn't even doing cocaine anymore
so I was up all night on just you know
just on the Lord's cocaine just air
oxygen and and having to just get that
thing up I remember being in Illinois
last year and I had to drive to
somebody's yard get close enough to
their house and steal their internet cuz
it's middle of nowhere and use their
internet to upload at five megabytes per
second or something you know that lady
came out in the morning she's all
[ __ ] pissed trying to get me to leave
I said I can't leave for 11 minutes I
said I've been uploading this thing for
two and a half hours and if I pull off
even six feet away from your house right
now
this thing's it's gonna stop and I'm
have to start over man just you know a
lot of different times but then you know
with the beauty and this has been for me
is just that you guys showed up in that
I had to get it up and that we we did it
you know that's my favorite pronoun a
lot of times is we you know sometimes he
will be like oh man you come in when you
come to perform and I'll be like oh we
are coming at this time I use we a lot
somebody like would you this weekend
I've got go we went to because I don't
like to feel alone I think not rather
just somebody assumed that I'm not alone
and maybe maybe I'm I'd rather me assume
i'm not i think the same by saying we a
lot makes me feel that way but yeah man
I'm trying I'm trying to think of some
of the other times but I do feel a
little out of my element here in this
hotel so but yeah a lot of times we put
this thing up one camera I did an
episode in a car one night just by the
light of the little the light in the
front oh we have some cool guests coming
up dr. Drew is gonna come in just locked
him down to come in so that Chris Ryan
episode was really interesting I thought
you know I want to talk to him more we
just talked really about you know one of
the things I felt like we talked about
was you know if you if you want to be in
a more open sexual environment but I
would love to hear his thoughts more on
you know what it's like because a lot of
people that's not what they that's not
going to help them you know a lot of
people that's not fitting for their life
you know talking to my brother and he
was saying that you know there's
something special when you have a
connection with somebody and you come
home and you know when you both you guys
have been or you know have been good to
each other and you guys are in a
marriage that's connected that there's
there's nothing like that feeling you
know of having that person and having
that nest that you know even that
sensual that where it all comes together
kind of in some of those moments of even
just laying next to each other you know
then there's something there's a real as
much as there is a bravery for men and
women that are open to try open
relationships and be able to communicate
honestly there's a bravery and a there's
a there's something amazing about the
stick-to-itiveness of people to say this
is the choice I've made and this is the
choice I'm gonna make the most of and I
wish we'd had gotten in a little bit
more that I wanted to pick his brain a
little but I'm still learning how to the
interview you know I'm still learning
you know how to listen and but it's just
been great Menace this whole experience
has been super and I'm so excited to be
able to reach out to new guests and if
you have a guest that you want on let us
know who they are and let them know say
hey you would be great they send them a
DM send them a message and say hey you
would be great on this guy's podcast you
should go on there let's take this call
here Co what's up man it's Chuck listen
I just realized I think I may be in a
little bit of a dark arts business
myself
no big Chuck is out there DEA and huh
you sleepwalking you sleepwalking in
motels huh you sleepwalk at a Ramada
somebody will [ __ ] pull out a piece
stole bro okay home Burt them in that
taxidermy game really now that might be
a dark art but you hide in cotton in the
bodies of of animals Jane Doe you making
stuffed animals out of real animals
dude the reason why we came out with
stuffed animals is because we didn't
want people like you doing all that
ahead that's crazy to me man think about
that you know think about this though
what if they started doing taxidermy for
people you know you could have your
grandfather that has had both of his
arms up in the air and you could make
him in like a coat rack put his tongue
coming out his mouth you could hang your
hat right there two coats on him or
maybe six coats if he's a strong
grandparent if he you know still didn't
have much osteoporosis and you could
have him just right by the door just all
taxidermied up you know don't forget
your jacket pop-pop has it let's hear
more thanks for calling Chuck you know
we're like people go out and find an
animal that's not quite ready to be dead
but they make it dead and then bring it
to me in hopes that I can make it look
alive again whoa I didn't think about
that because I bet that's starting to
happen so there's so many people that
are I think it's good it's wonderful to
be an animal lover and because if you
can love an animal it just shows I mean
that's just practice for loving humans
and that's a beautiful thing I mean you
know there's so many creatures out there
you know and mother nature knows what
she's doing with all of them and even a
junebug you know probably have feelings
you know and it probably has feelings
all all year around but to think that
there's probably people that are
starting to overly love animals like to
the point where I think it's not healthy
I think there are animal addicts and I
could see now that you mentioned this
Chuck I could see someone wanting to
keep an animal in its prime and so then
they exterminate their animal their own
loved animal just to have a taxidermy to
keep it how they want it and that's I
mean that is I mean that's real that's
all but that's pretty much sorcery when
you look at that that is that's probably
grade-a sorcery
more chuck and sometimes people just
bring delicious animals that they've
eaten and they want them to look like
they did before they were eaten so it's
just a lot of different reasons but what
wait hold on people bring delicious
animals that they've eaten they want to
look like oh oh so you're saying maybe
somebody get that Thanksgiving turkey
you know that prized bird that prized
seasonal Partridge and they eat it and
but then they want it to look like they
didn't eat it that's a new diet more but
I just got to thinking about it and
afraid that the taxidermy might be in a
dark horse not that I'm getting out but
it's definitely borderline at least oh
why don't I mean yours definitely
perverse it's definitely perverse if
you're stuffing cotton or textiles in
with the deceased body of an animal dude
that's Slytherin there's no man you
ain't Gryffindor Daddy
that's Slytherin and if you can sleep at
night
then that's very interesting to me all
right let's take another call here here
we go homeward do this week oh and I'm a
driver
their delivery to restaurants what's up
Rico thank you for being a driver and
thank you for delivering two restaurants
man you know my mother delivers
newspapers and she delivers different
items too when I was young she used to
deliver cookies they had a company
called Fortman vo all our tea ma in and
she would get these huge cases of
cookies I mean one of them boxes
probably had 400 cookies ginger snaps
and you could smell I was a kid so you
could smell that [ __ ] ginger dude and
I know she would have all these boxes
she had this Volkswagen Rabbit and my
mother would have that thing stacked to
the [ __ ] brim boy about 600 pounds of
sweet rounds in that thing of cookies
and man I would get it sometime I would
sneak her keys out of her purse and I
would go in there at night in that car
and I would open the door and I would
lay on top of all those cookies man and
I would just sleep right there on top of
those cookies and man there was nothing
more
there was nothing more wonderful for me
than that I mean it was just imagine the
smell at that point I'm laying on top of
no joke probably twenty five hundred
individual cookies all grouped together
in boxes I mean that's like an that is a
that's like an army of cookies and I
could just smell them all man coming
into my body and coming into my [ __ ]
system and this is before I start I'm
glad I wasn't you know masturbating or
anything at that point cuz you're gonna
tell me you're telling me that you
wouldn't you laying on in a bed of 2,500
sweet treats and you ain't gonna just
make your own frosting yeah man yeah man
let's hear more anyway I just got a
suggestive for you bro you know I'm a
recovering drug addict man well I
appreciate you calling and
congratulations you're in recovery
that's a brave thing you know I you know
one thing about being here in San
Francisco it is I mean you walk down the
street
two people shooting up here shooting up
and in LA in Los Angeles you can see
that by Skid Row and stuff like that but
I've never seen that just out in the
wild and you know in normal areas you
know you like you're looking in a window
and they got a gap or something and then
you look over and they got a dude
putting a needle into one of his gaps so
it's definitely it's different here
so congratulations on being a recovering
drug addict oh this reminds me really
quick listen listen your call and then
I'll go into my story onward I actually
read this book by Russell Brand the
comedian
cover cover II and I think maybe you
could see if you could have him on as a
guest and you can interview him he was
on Joe Rogan's podcast it was a real
good interview but they don't really
talk too much about the drug addiction
and drug addictions excuse me and you
know just check it out see what can
happen and keep it up man and even if
you can't get them or whatever but just
a suggestion Tom I appreciate the
suggestion there Rico thank you thank
you for calling a man and best of luck
to you and your recovery dude that's
brave of you that's brave man and you
doing brave stuff for yourself and
that's inspiring
I remember this remind me the first time
I ever came to San Francisco and I came
here I was working as a tour manager for
a musician and I came here and we got
into town we got into the hotel and next
thing you know we go outside in it's
dark out it's late and we were in an
area there wasn't a lot of food
opportunities there wasn't a lot of
places where you could really say she
ate your stomach and enjoy and fill your
body with food and I walked outside and
they had a homeless guy are you look he
was homeless but he definitely it looked
like if he had a home that he hadn't
been there and maybe two or three years
so at least a dude that had lost his
keys and his address and he um and I was
like what is that guy doing he was
looking at this was in gap that store
gap was really popular and they had
models in the windows and a picture of a
beautiful brunette girl kind of
rubenesque a little bit you know a
little you know natural looking a
regular lady and but she was very
beautiful shift freckled skin and
red hair and I like red hair and I like
other colors too but I also I do like
red hair and because that's the fire you
know I'm saying when you got [ __ ]
straight fire coming out of your body
via your hair whoo yeah yeah so but this
man he ran across the street they had a
plug in an outdoor plug in he had a
radio like a like a plug in radio where
you find a radio station transistor
radio he runs across the street plugs it
in and he Tunes it and he put it on
Norah Jones this was a musician that was
popular and she had a song called come
away with me then this man ran across
the street back to the gap ad now with
Norah Jones just filling this street up
and there was nobody else around it was
a it was just a dead area I was like an
area where people who I guess would shop
a lot during the day so at night those
areas are generally pretty dead because
that's more of a commercial district and
and this man started masturbating and
touching himself outdoors and touching
his own body and touching his dick
outdoors and it you know it made me feel
like wow like even even at the lowest
you know and I don't want to the lowest
levels of humanity but even at a very
visceral level of humanity like being
homeless or haven't been not home in a
long time and being dirty and being that
there was still some romance in this man
there was still you know he wasn't just
gonna jerk off to this woman he didn't
know in the window you know he had
chosen to put on some music and make it
a moment and that was just uh I don't
know I don't know what that did to me in
the rest of my life or what it continues
to do or how that will come into play in
my future but it was very interesting to
see that even at such low at such a you
know we would consider a low level of
existence that that that man had chosen
to make a moment you know and I guess we
can do that
no matter how tough things are you know
if we can do it make it that little
extra step you know we can maybe take
ourselves out of out of the exactness of
what something is you know because this
man was just jerking off outside of a
gap outside of business hours but when
he put the music on it filled the
streets and this woman's voice was
beautiful and you didn't I didn't I
don't know it was almost like a ballet
you know like a ballet with a dick in it
kind of I don't know I'm out of my mind
it's been a crazy weekend anyway let's
hear more thank you for calling about
that recommendation now there's a good
example go tell Russell Brand to come on
this podcast and I'll tell him to I will
ask him let's take another call here
here we go the oh it's Jay again in
Denver
how you doing me thanks for calling Jay
in Denver and what did I just see in
Denver oh they had a man who worked for
the FBI he was dancing at a party did a
backflip his gun flew out of his belt
and landed on the ground
when he picked it up he accidentally
shot somebody in the crowd so there you
go let's hear more you killing it as
always of course I'm still supporting
the PIO Vaughn it was such an honor to
be on the show man it was great to talk
to you in that way and of course I
called back to talk about our exam but I
want your perspective man I know you're
planning to talk on it if you haven't
already but in the spirit of the CEO I
think the best thing that you're telling
this is this rose and Valerie Jarrett
talked to each other maybe for the
people for the people to see I
appreciate you asking what my thoughts
are on it and and if you guys have
thoughts on you don't want to know my
thoughts on something you're always
welcome to call and ask me and you can
hit the hotline for any questions or any
issues you have nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three you know what
I love that idea because in that idea
you're gonna get you know we're in this
time where you don't nobody wants the
full nobody wants to know why people do
something anymore but I believe that
people do want to know I believe that I
don't
that Twitter is a great source for
anything Twitter is just I mean Twitter
is like it's like Junior it's like
middle school but I think that on the
Roseann topic I mean first of all
Roseanne is from a different you know
she's gonna say edgy wild [ __ ]
she's Roseanne who do you think she is
you think she's not Roseanne you think
she's Dakota Fanning
you think she's um Debbie Schultz
Wasserman or you think she's Busta
Rhymes know she's Roseanne Barr she
grabbed her vulva one time and spit
during the national anthem she is
Roseanne so it's somebody surprised that
she made you know disparaging comments
or even racial comments as somebody on
Twitter you know I think it's it's wild
how we ever anything that even could be
racist now is definitely racist but it's
like what do you expect out of Roseanne
that's what you're gonna get and it's
also what do you expect when you give a
65 year old or whatever she is 63 or
something a Twitter account it's like
that's what you're gonna get so I'm not
surprised by it at all I also seem like
some stuff was going on over there with
that show maybe people didn't like
working there with her or didn't like
the environment you know I know Whitney
Cummings had been working there and then
quit the show or this was a few weeks
ago this was a few weeks before the
debacle happened with Roseanne and how
she was tweeting and how she gets into
the politics of it all and it's just I
mean it is a time where if you have a
conservative voice or you're angry at
ads I mean Hollywood is devoutly liberal
and you can't speak on it it you can't
and it's almost better for you really
not to get into it because these days we
are being a like performers everyone is
being inhaled it seems like
- you know they're being held everything
you do can affect everything you do you
know you're being held your character
your human your character as a human can
affect your character on a show if you
play on a show and it's um it's just a
different time do I think that that's
great - I wish we didn't have that I
wish we didn't know what anybody's
political views were you know I really
wish that a lot of times and I think if
you meet somebody in person then you you
a lot of times you don't know you know
it used to be the thing was a couple
things you don't talk about politics and
your sex life because you know those
things would cause controversy and those
things would you know anger people or
those things would start arguments but I
do think that the best thing I don't
know if ABC made the best move by
canceling the show because then everyone
is affected by her choice I mean that
gives her in a weird way gave her a lot
of power and it gave her a lot of you
know she made that mistake she did that
you know of course look some people say
look she [ __ ] tweeted what she wants
who gives a [ __ ] yeah keine she's a
comedian I can understand if she's
running a school and she says that but
she's a comedian she wants to be edgy
she wants to say something ridiculous
I'm not surprised by that she's a she's
a [ __ ] comedian she's not a chef so
you know it's weird it's like you don't
let somebody be a comedian anymore
let's quit calling it comedy or you know
and I don't know if you maybe she wasn't
trying to be funny maybe she was just
being mean you know I don't know some of
the gist of all of it but it didn't seem
like you know she didn't I don't know me
she didn't use the n-word but she
definitely it was just dumb it was just
dumb by her cuz she knows she knows that
she knows better and maybe she was on
ambien maybe she's 65 I mean there's
that look there's a
possibilities but yeah I would have
loved to have seen those two women be
able to sit and talk about it you know
we have this weird thing where once we
can actually learn something from a
situation especially with Hollywood they
shut it down you know I've said this
before with the 18 Kids and Counting or
whatever that TV show remember that and
they had one of the kids to touch
another ones titty or kid titty whatever
it's called when you're a kid I don't
think that's like a just a kid titty and
and then they shut the whole show down
because some you know allegations that
come out that when when one of the kids
was 11 and one of the kids was 15 that
one of the kids had touched one of the
one of the what the boy had touched one
of the girls there's 17 or 18 kids in
the house had touched one of them's
vagina or titty and first of all I've
said this before but when you have 18
kids in a house you can't even reach for
the lights which probably without
touching somebody's ass there's just too
many body parts in the environment but
also I thought well this is a great time
for us to have a for people to have a
conversation about what happens when
you're kids and if something kind of
weird happens at the house like if they
give it and I could be getting the ages
wrong but I think there were both
children they were both you know they
weren't adults so and look we've all
looked I had to I had some I had some
weird stuff happen when I was a kid you
know they just have a man in our
neighborhood would give us 20 bucks and
he'd go and spread his ass cheeks about
40 feet away from us and just pay us to
look at his frickin browser hole you
know just to stare over that uh you know
that little that deal he had you know
when sometimes you play that song
brown-eyed girl to on his car stereo
while while he did it you know that was
weird
armor being really young and hugging my
sister like extremely hard and pressing
her against my body because I got some
sort of minoo feeling of I don't know if
it was sexual at the time I didn't know
it was sexual feelings I just I got some
different feeling and I wouldn't you
know doing anything you know overtly
dirty
but but it just seemed like it would
have been a good sometimes just a good
time for her and that same guy was now
older on that 18 Kids and Counting show
and he had gotten busted on those Adult
Friend Finder or Ashley brown whatever
that website is called Ashley Brown
where people log on and try to find
other people's genitalia within like a
25 mile radius or whatever to go over
and smell and touch and be around but
and I thought well this is also a great
time to find out about adultery and why
this man does it and lets that the now
more than ever I wanted to see that show
I've never seen it but now I wanted to
see it when we can learn but so many
times we shut things down right when
it's a great opportunity for us to
really actually learn and really share
because man it's like we're just in such
a desperate time to really connect and
and some of these powers that that
control a lot of stuff they don't do it
they don't let us do it I don't love to
have a have a car because we just we
need to have some more conversations we
need to have them because otherwise
we're just we're in this word fight and
it's just I don't know it's kind of
scary but I appreciate you calling on me
to go off on that guys I don't wanna you
know if people are tired of hearing
about that then that's just wasting
people's listening time let's take
another call here we go hey man this is
Alex from Baltimore Maryland I just
wanna let you know Baltimore man a great
place to join the Navy and also to get
on to opiates I've seen people walking
on the street in Baltimore both eyes
closed walk seven eight blocks and
that's that's brave [ __ ] man oh we're
but man absolutely loves your your
comedy recently found out of you about
your podcast it's really been helping me
get through a kind of a tough time ended
a relationship with somebody been
together with this girl for about six
and a half years Wow oh that's a
commitment man that's a man
just two marriages these days that's a
commitment man I'm sorry to hear that
more we're all set to get engaged and uh
she called it off and also involved a
house so there's that
ooh so you had the mayor's you got she
called it off and that must have been
tough on her too oh let's hear more
homework see a lost girlfriend and a
house and happened about four months ago
you know pretty tough time getting
through it but man I've been listening
to your podcast you know just about
every day and I'll you know it cracks me
up and it's you know nice to hear that
you know everybody else you know
everybody's got their struggle and yeah
I just want to say I appreciate it thank
you Alex you're welcome we're happy that
we're here to yeah and people calling
and talking about their struggles man
it's like that's who we are that's who I
am for me I am my struggles man I am my
struggles because the struggle is when I
the more I see it like I've never
reached a goal in my life and been like
I reached a time in my life and been
like aw man
finally everything's perfect nah it's
the struggles that's where the walk
that's where the you know is when you're
is when you're in the trenches it's when
you're having to make choices when
you're having to lay there with your
eyes open it's when you're having to
show up for yourself is when you're
having to tell somebody how you feel
even though it hurts
it's when you have it's when you you're
on your way home and you get a call from
a friend or something they need
something like [ __ ] but you go you know
it's the it's the jerk it's the [ __ ]
struggles man that's who we are that's
who I mean that's what that's where I
learned Who I am you know I don't get to
a you know it's not like you win a game
and they that it feels good to win but
the the part that was it was the moments
you made the plays that felt that
without that was the the meet that was
the meet but you know I can only imagine
how tough that is but I know there's
better things on the horizon for you
were different things you know you never
know man that girl might have she might
get hit by lightning and I'm not hoping
that for her she sound like a nice lady
but you never know
and guess what guess what about
lightning dude it could kill a couple
people at once so and maybe that house
maybe that whole [ __ ] thing is
burning down you know it's just a you
know you don't know that's another thing
boy mother nature boy when she wants to
crack that lightning whip you know you
never know who's gonna get it but thanks
for calling Alex let's take a call here
this is a response we got a couple of
responses to last week's episode here we
go yo Theo
this is Rio Phil y'all in on what you
can do as far as you know getting good
prices out of shop okay yeah we had a
call last week and I maybe the week
before I think the gentleman's name was
Michael I'm not sure but about how to
get how to get treat he was worried
about how to get treated fairly this was
a gentleman the military's been worried
about how to get treated fairly by a
mechanic and here we have a mechanic
callin from South Georgia and I know
they got vehicles breaking down over
there in South Georgia
more you need a fun
you're good job and you need to be loyal
to them you need to make friends with a
mechanic they're having a mechanic as a
friend will definitely help you out you
can call them he'll tell you the price
right there you go and that's kind of a
you know but that's a simple than that's
a straightforward answer is going there
I think in you know and and one thing
like I've mentioned that can you know
that I suggested the Creek could create
friendship is just being earnest with
them because you know if I do [ __ ]
here's a thing if you want to [ __ ] me
gonna [ __ ] me but if I'm earnest with
you and you [ __ ] me man I know you don't
sleep that strong at night I know you
don't
I know you don't because when I give you
that earnestness and I give you that
honesty and say hey look I you know I
don't know how to do this and I'm you
know I have some nerves I when you're
vulnerable in that moment and that man
[ __ ] you that's that hangs on him
that's a dirty ornament hanging on his
inner tree and that I want him it might
even have a jingle bell in it so here's
that thing flare up and that's his
that's his dirty ornament that he's
hanging inside of himself when you show
up with that vulnerability but thank you
for calling very much there here we go
we got a call that came in for the the
woman from Saudi Arabia called in and I
actually took the call on to the
doctor's room and Adam Carolla podcast
the other day and we we had a dancers on
there by dr. drew and we're gonna try to
package that up and we'll put that out
this week a series of the answer that
happened there and the answer that came
in on here on this past weekend from
Chris Ryan but here's some suggestions
that you guys offered here we go Giovani
it is more from philadelphia garden
again I was calling because of the grave
woman from Saudi Arabia that called your
podcast to talk to you about suffering
with depression and suicidal thoughts
and anxiety and everything first off I
just wanted to say that it kicked ass
that she actually asked somebody for
help I agree with you you know it takes
something to do that it takes something
to ask for help and mana you know I got
to start putting some notes up around my
house or my apartment because I don't
really actually have a house but that
say that remind me that you know I have
to be brave enough to ask for help you
know cuz I need it let's hear more
though second thank you for creating a
place where she could call to do that
third I had a couple of suggestions for
her because I also deal with the same
than it is a lot very difficult in this
world to feel like you actually have a
purpose and you're contributing theme oh
that's such a big statement yeah we
don't we want that that's what we really
want we want to feel like we have a
purpose you know we really want to feel
purposeful homeward main way I found to
combat that is to think about the things
I get
to do while I'm here things that I
actually like and whatever those things
are I try to do them as often as I can
because you feel good and that way if
you plan ahead for something that you
really enjoy you always have something
to look forward to so that's one thing
that you can do another is writing all
that stuff down whatever you have going
on in your head or whatever you feel
like in that moment if you're upset if
you're sad if you're happy it's really
good to sit and write those things down
on paper because otherwise your brain
turns into an echo chamber for the dark
arts no bueno oh and that's Spanish at
the end she hit us with that flare at
the end with that viola thank you for
that that's true you know the brain is a
dirty echo chamber isn't it man my
thingy that goes into my my brain it'll
go down and in my heart it'll come back
through it'll go up and down and just
just cavernous man I got these caverns
in me let's hear another suggestion that
came in thank you for that call Laura
let's hear another suggestion for the
Saudi Arabia caller homeward hey Steve
Lawrence from Miami just listen to the
podcast love the podcast Oh Miami
Lawrence boy Oh daddy more as much as as
much as you have me Diane laughing all
the time when I heard Amy Amy Amy from
Saudi Arabia called in they just
absolutely broke my heart I read a book
while back that helps change my life I'm
not sure if it'll work for her it's
called the power of now hopefully you
can recommend this book to her hopefully
it'll work for her and also just one
once I want her to know that down here
at Miami we appreciate her courage for
having the strength to call in and I
weren't her to know that she needs to be
good to herself because she definitely
deserved it I Love You Man
oh thanks for that message Lauren
Lawrence sorry Lawrence Thank You Man
yeah you know it's true it's a man we're
out here we're out here we we are out
here that's why I say we right there
because man you know things [ __ ] can
happen when people try to do stuff gang
and that's a great suggestion and I hope
she hears this and I know that there on
the hotline there's a number where the
call came from and we'll make sure that
she gets a link to this episode she can
hear people's suggestions we're gonna
package it all up for her with dr. Drew
Pinsky advice and also with dr.
Christopher Ryan's suggestions for
whenever we played that call for him the
other day let's get into another call
here this one let's go question for you
about it let's say about eight nine
years old I go to this this summer camp
okay you're eight or nine you're at
summer camp go on they do a lot of funny
fun activities one of the activities of
a camp counselor Colorado was the
wrestling match but it wasn't just any
wrestling match it was a big open water
like real slippery type on the slip and
slide tight now okay well that sounds
fun you guys are playing a slip and
slide and they got soap and water
wrestling no more wrestling match I mean
it wasn't between the kids but it was
mostly between capes trying to take down
the camp counselor this is a big dude
I'm talking like a bear big ol hairy guy
Here I am eight years old and I'm
thinking like WrestleMania ww me type
[ __ ] so I'm trying to bring them down
I'm wrestling to the ground and the kid
it seemed like a wrestling match but the
older I get the more I'm starting to
think that something funny might have
been going on there what's your opinion
on that oh it seemed like y'all guys
soaked up I mean if a man has six or
seven soaked up children climbing all
over his body
yeah do this I mean I would just be
grateful you didn't get molested
honestly you know because you didn't get
molested you definitely I think you
probably fulfilled some erotic thoughts
of his you know he's probably just
feeling all this you know those
energetic soapy just Nino's I'm going
over his skin and just you know just not
having you know 12 you know kids
eggs wrapped around his neck at the same
time he probably was feeling something
wild but I'm grateful that y'all didn't
get molested that's where I would just
keep it right there and just find some
gratitude in that thank you for calling
let's go here we go
I fear my name is Raj I'm a comic and I
saw that you're looking to have
nominations sent in for a single mom to
come check out your show Saturday
Cherokee Casino hey Raj I certainly am a
fellow comedian Raj yes we are at
Cherokee Casino there in West Siloam we
want to do something I want to get a
single mom out more so my nomination is
a lady by the name of Kristen Switzer
Lou Switzer
she's the office admin at my day job she
looks super hard she has a little
daughter and just one the most positive
people I know she does a ton for a
community and does a ton of fundraising
for like animal shelters and stuff like
that so Kristen is my is my nomination
awesome well thank you so much for that
yeah man I'll reach out to you tomorrow
and we'll get in touch and see what we
can do for her you may have already
mentioned it too if you haven't don't
mention it to her yet lets you and I
discuss it first but thank you for
calling and yeah that's awesome man you
know it makes me feel and some people
might be wondering why you know what our
plan is with that and I think it's just
you know I remember when I was a kid you
know I didn't get like so really I guess
it's more like me when I'm an adult you
know my mother and I have never laughed
together and I don't know why that is
and and that's okay at this point in my
life
we may not that's okay but that still
doesn't mean that I don't want to know I
when I think even in my mother's life I
don't know if she ever has laughed in
her life really I mean I know there's
some moments where I have seen her laugh
but has she ever just been somewhere and
just laughed and
and felt taken care of at the same time
because there's a different type of
laugh you can have when you when you
feel taken care of you know when that
stress of them of every moment isn't
sitting on your skin isn't hanging on
your tree you can there's other if you
can feel more intensely and you can be
more open to joy and so I would just
love to I wish I there was a moment I
could remember when I was young that I
knew that my mom and one of her friends
or something went out to a place and
just laughed
she didn't go somewhere and just get
wasted and you know maybe some man be
rude to her or something like that or
you know or she you know came home and
you know was alone and just you know
back in our apartment which was sinking
in the mud and you know felt depressed
or you know it would be nice just to
know because I don't have that memory
but man to think that you know some
higher power gave me a gift to tell
jokes you know to make people laugh or
to make them to make them feel okay
that's what I want to do you know and I
don't even think man I know this sounds
crazy but I don't feel like I write a
lot of my jokes and stuff I feel like if
I take care of myself that I am this
isn't my doing and I'm not saying it's
God am I getting on some hokey level
there but I do feel like I'm a conduit
for for whatever and if I can take care
of myself then I can best be utilized
and if my little gift happens to be look
tons of [ __ ] I'm not good at to you know
but one thing I can do is
you know I can if I'm in a good place I
can make people laugh and sin and if I
could you know if I knew there was a
moment in my life where I remembered oh
remember when mom went out and my mother
honestly didn't have any friends because
I think you know she was just you know
my mother's man and am I talking ill
about my mother I love my mother and I
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for her and
my mother you know I know she loves me
sometimes I wish that she there were
other parts of her heart maybe that
could be unlocked more so that she could
love two levels that that I don't know
if she knows exists but that's just my
perception I don't know if that's true
for her she may love me so immensely but
if I could think back in know there was
a time where somebody took care of man
just made her feel joy and didn't ask
anything in return you know that a man
and also to know that a man did that for
my mother and didn't leave her with any
burden and I mother had to work all the
time dude my mother's always worked
always I can't think of a time when even
I've asked her want to do something just
pending work you know and maybe
sometimes I think I might've gone out
and laid in that car just to even be
around her for a little bit even though
she wasn't in there you know it was a
place I knew she was so much running
around driving that car that if I could
just be in there for a little while by
myself you know maybe it was a smell of
my mother honestly I don't know you know
where were such creatures as children
we're such we're such animals
we're such junebugs aren't we but yeah
but that's so that's our goal and we'll
we service that I don't know this [ __ ]
my [ __ ] be ridiculous you know we
might have the first mother and her
friend go out and they get in a [ __ ]
fistfight in the front row of the show
who knows
but but man I would love to have that
memory that my mother got to go out and
not have had to and just know that
everything was okay and be able to laugh
and have some join so that's our goal
and thank you for calling it Raj because
you helped him right now let's hear more
all word CEO it's your girl Ashland I'm
in Osaka Japan oh hi Jimmy must be how
do we must stay and that means our
friendship begins in Japanese that's the
only thing that I know thanks for
calling and I just want to say [ __ ]
thank you and I was so happy to see
Chris Ryan on your podcast on your show
that a me so happy oh that's cool yeah
me too he's an interesting man I look
forward to talking to him more I'm gonna
know what it's like you know trying to
help people because it seems like you
devote a lot of your energy to answering
other people's questions but I wonder
you know maybe talking to people like
Chris Ryan and helps you do you feel
some kind of like deep responsibility
the kind of calls that you get man how
do you balance that with just a real
recognition of your own and fault and
sorry an email came in let's hear the
end of that again a recognition of your
own humaneness and fault and it's a lot
of responsibility you know how do you
handle that you know it's a good
question and maybe this is a mom alright
you no need to say you know talk about
needing help and we get a lot of calls
like I be I would be lying to you if I
tell you we didn't have if we didn't
have 600 calls come in this week that's
a lot and it's a lot of it some of us
fun stuff and look I've even gotten to
listen to all of them yet you know and I
don't know if this is a codependency or
something
me but I feel you know I just it makes
me sad like if people are hurting you
know I don't that sounds [ __ ] crazy
Brian I'm not trying to be like a weirdo
or anything but it just makes me sad you
know and I think it's easier for me
probably to relate to young men that are
feeling certain types of ways because
I'm a young man but it just makes me say
it you know and it makes me you know I'm
a late bloomer I've been a late bloomer
a lot of things in my life you know and
a lot of my life I lived in fear and I
feel like um I'm starting to get out of
that now
um and so I'm learning I'm in a moment I
mean I'm going through a lot of faith in
my life I'm learning a lot about myself
and I'm on I find myself even being more
on a quest to learn and learn why I feel
because for the first time in the past
years I've started to have feelings
since I got into sobriety I just started
to have more feelings dude I never had
them like so so I think I'm I'm addicted
to it in a way but I just want to you
know I try to keep it healthy and I
don't know this show this show is just
kind of morphed into a place where
people can offer suggestions to try and
help other people through their
experience and and their strength and
hope and I have the idea that you know
sometimes people can call in and if they
don't feel alone then that's the first
great step and sometimes that's you know
that what can we really do I don't know
but you know sometimes yeah I wish there
was more ways to help people but maybe
we'll learn more as this show goes on
and we can figure more out but I don't
know it you know I just I'm glad to know
that people are out there feeling I'm
glad to know that it's important and I
think it's the most real thing about
ourselves
you know is what are we feeling man
what's going on you know there's just so
much [ __ ] out here these days it's just
so not real and our time here is so
limited it's like let's [ __ ] let's
say I don't know you know I don't know I
don't know but I appreciate that call
and how do we - our friendship begins
this thing came in from a dude named
Benjamin dust bear here we go hey bear
again from Portal off again I do not
remember the first time but that DBZ boy
that dank gang that does bow and he's
got a song for us let's hear it
Wow my mom don't even have to do a land
is mine the old bones got this row he's
a master you don't even have to smoke a
joint you don't even have to top of
champers yo wrong we got the clothes he
needs my mom got the truths in his mind
you don't even have to pop the squat all
right man the song got out of line there
but I appreciate it thanks for calling
in there Benjamin yeah you know I'm
grateful to everybody that's called this
week there are a lot more calls we'll
get into a regular episode maybe we'll
do like a more regular episode on
Thursday instead of having a guest in on
that episode you know it's just tough
for me I self to edit this and put it up
here because we don't have any producers
producer help here but but thank you
guys you know thank you and yeah I don't
know sometimes exactly what we're doing
you know [ __ ] I don't know what were
[ __ ] doing anything dude you know I
mean but
but we're here we're here on earth you
know and we have a lot of templates in
our lives that we have to live by you
know we have we have to have jobs and we
have to do this and we have to eat and
we have to but we also we gotta you know
we gotta we can do whatever we want and
we can feel you know and I'm trying to
feel all the [ __ ] feelings man you
know and I feel like there's we can mix
like humor and feelings because for me
the best humor comes out of those
moments you know is one thing I think it
for me that happened when my dad was so
old growing up and I know I say that a
lot but you know having like a man
watching like a 70 year old man 75 year
old man chase you around the house of
the belt you know and I remember my
brother and I would hide under my
mother's bed and and uh and we would in
dude it would take my dad 30 seconds to
get kneel down onto the floor to swing
the belt under the bed at us and it came
by at like the slowest belt ever but we
would scream like it hit us and we would
make you know we would we had to sir
you know we had to so it was so funny my
brother and I are laughing so hard at
this man that we love our father and at
the same time screaming as if we're
getting hit to make him and my mother
believe that we were getting spanked you
know and then my mother never you know
my father was never allowed to sleep in
their room so he slept on the couch
every night and so there was just all
these weird feelings where there was
just like so much real [ __ ] and so much
humor going on at the same time you know
because we were just goofy kids
you know and we would always think my
dad wasn't alive and he was just asleep
but you know every time I senior citizen
goes to sleep bro you got that you know
you got that 9% you got that 9% chance
and that theta it's gonna sleep walk up
on up to heaven so I don't know I live
in this way you know I don't know if I
live in this weird world but I think
part of that weird weird world is inside
of me where there's some humor and some
there's some humor and some reality and
they they're just friends I don't know
maybe some of the dark arts are good but
thank you guys so much for getting in
touch and for reaching out the hotline
ninety five six six four nine five zero
three herp alert remember if you got
that check it out h er p al e rt.com and
you can really just get it solved and
get yourself taken care of so that way
you don't infect nobody else and if you
got a baby or you got a you know a
skinless animal or not skinless that's
that's the [ __ ] I've bet that
taxidermy dude flared up that was a a
slip if you have a hairless animal and
they want to you know they probably
could get herpes easy from you if y'all
hugging and [ __ ] kind of you not kiss
him but letting them lick on your face
and everything some people do that with
their animals and this pretty crazy to
me but but anyway be good to yourselves
you probably deserve a thank you guys
for the calls we made it through this
cluster this cluster fest I had all the
feelings this week man the high the low
I don't know I don't know but man can
you believe [ __ ] Mickey gets to go
skydiving dude I haven't even told him
yet so I don't know if anybody's even
told them go to his uh instagrams tell
them if y'all want but yeah that was a
nice thing in the this man Sean from
Ridge suggested it and they want to they
just love this story and that's crazy
he's got them crack addict airbags in
his body boy next thing you know
trickling mickey out here in the
Tenderloin blowing dudes or even blowing
ladies out here you know they got all of
its all of its natural out here all of
its natural
you guys be good to yourselves man you
probably deserved it
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
[Music]
while we all die
celebrate our
celebrate Oh
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]